Well, this is interesting.
When the Bidens moved
into the White House,
they brought their two dogs
with them, Champ and Major.
There they are, beautiful
German shepherds.
Well, here's the thing.
When there are dogs in the White House,
the Secret Service has a
special canine security detail.
It protects the dogs, yeah.
I'm curious what it's like
protecting the President's dog,
so I wanted to find out.
Joining me now, canine
Special Agent James Duncan.
Hello, Agent Duncan.
Hello, Mr. O'Brien.
Now let me get this straight, sir.
You're the Secret Service agent assigned
to protect Champ and
Major, is that correct?
Yes, sir.
That's correct, and as a
matter of fact, I've got,
I've got Champ and Major right here
at my feet as we speak, sir.
Oh, great.
This is cool.
Can we see them?
Is it, is that possible?
No, I'm afraid not.
You know, it is a security thing,
and also I am, I'm not
allowed to tip the, the camera
down towards my lap anymore on Zoom calls.
Right, right.
That's been, people have been getting
in trouble for that, yeah.
So let's get to the point.
If you're a canine security agent,
what were you doing the last four years?
I mean, famously the
Trumps did not have dogs.
No, sir.
They did not have a dog, but
they did have Eric Trump, sir,
and I was assigned to him.
All right, but Eric Trump is not a dog.
Nobody said Eric Trump was a dog, okay.
People like dogs.
People want to be around dogs.
Dogs can learn new things,
but we did feel that there was
enough psychological overlap
between dogs and Eric that,
that I could work with him.
Okay, well what do you mean by that?
Well, Eric Trump is, he's energetic.
He's eager to please.
He's spoiled as hell.
I mean, I got to tell ya, and
he loves to chase a Frisbee
and he is capable of being
a very, very good boy.
Oh, okay.
So there are, I see that,
there's yeah, I see.
Yeah, the first time I met him, he was
extremely suspicious of me,
but as soon as he got up there
and sniffed my crotch, we, we
became friends and you know,
soon thereafter he was
sleeping at the foot
of my bed every night.
I'm sorry, Eric slept
at the foot of your bed?
Yes, sir.
Oh, unless I had a lady spend the night.
Then it was back in the crate.
Ah, yeah.
You got to, you can't
have him roaming around.
Actually, you know, I
couldn't ask for a nicer boy
if I'm being honest with
you and I, and I brought
some pictures I'd like to
show you if you'd like.
[Conan] Yeah, let's see these photos.
This is great.
Great, so this is a, this is Eric on the,
on the first warm day of spring.
[Conan] Actually got eight
nipples, that's odd, yeah.
Yes sir, yes sir, and he
loved having his tummy rubbed.
Ooh, we loved it.
Here's another one I took
on the Fourth of July.
[Conan] Ooh, he looks scared.
The, the fireworks really freaked him out.
It's actually, it's the only time
I saw him express his anal glands.
Yeah, okay.
We don't need to hear everything.
You could have skipped that part, okay.
Yeah, yes, sir.
Okay, well here's a happier time.
This is a photo of Eric with his family.
[Conan] I'm sorry, is that
a plastic cone on his head?
Yes, sir.
He got ear mites after, after
playing with Steve Bannon
and we tried to put a, a cream on his ear
but he kept rubbing it off and yeah.
Well, well anyway, Eric's
gone now and you have
two real dogs to look after.
How is it different now?
It's very different, sir.
First, Champ and Major
never tried to hump my leg
and you know, Eric was
always getting after it.
I had to use a squirt
gun to get him off me.
Let me just check here.
Yeah, yeah, both these guys
still have their testicles.
Ah, very good, and scene.
Special Agent James Duncan,
thank you for spending your time
and best of luck to you.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you for having me, Conan.